fear in belarus as police chase down
protesters
[Applause]
opposition to the regime met with a wall
of force
journalists also under attack they shoot
at journalists
even if you're with a press card with a
jacket
and all the press marks so it doesn't
matter it
even makes you a target now and
will you be out again to tonight with
your camera
yeah i'm going to continue to take
pictures
to the end of the protest are you
fearful for your life
afraid a bit but so looks
quite regular stuff and journalists work
so
i'm going to do my job
mass arrests too since an election last
sunday
saw belarus strongman alexander
lukashenko claim victory
and is opposition cry foul families
awaiting news of loved ones in detention
many see this woman as their rightful
president
but svetlana tikanaskaya was forced to
flee to next door lithuania
where she'd already sent her children
this activist accused the belarusian
security forces
of using threats against children to
crush descent
at january 2014 i am got the situation
when
kgb tried to kidnap my son he was only
one month
old this is horrible that for
many women journalists human rights
defenders politicians
activists this is unbelievable pressure
using children and using the chantash of
kidnapping children
for the first time a powerful committee
of lithuanian mps
have declared lukashenko's claim to the
presidency
illegitimate eu foreign ministers will
discuss the crisis on friday
and possible sanctions i personally
think that yet another
statement about deep concern will not
fly and
you know it doesn't work basically we
definitely if we mean what we're saying
it should be some
political consequences back in belarus
these women seek peaceful protest but
more violence appears inevitable
debra haynes sky news vilnius